[MUSIC PLAYING]
JASON POLITES: My name is Jason.
I'm a product manager
on Google Cloud.
My colleague Michael is going
to come up on stage a little bit
later and show you a demo.
So this is what's new
in serverless compute.
It's where we take you
through all the things we've
been working on since last Cloud
Next and some of the things
that are coming up soon.
We have quite a lot of
content to get through.
We'll do our best to
get through it all.
If there's any questions at
the end and we have time,
there's some microphones
here in the middle.
If we run out of time, we'll
be loitering outside the room
afterwards if you want to
grab us for a quick question.
And don't forget to write the
session at the end in the app.
That would be great.
So let's get into it.
Serverless on Google
Cloud is the way
we think about it is
more than just compute.
We have a view that
serverless covers
a full range of services.
The rationale here
is that if you
want to build your application
and you have an objective
to not touch a server and
not manage infrastructure,
you need to do that across
more than just compute.
However, for today,
we're going to focus just
on that compute portion.
And so there are many
other sessions that
will cover the other things.
Today it's just compute mostly.
We do have a few things that
perhaps deviate from that,
but mostly we scope to compute.
As far as compute goes
on Cloud Platform,
there's two products that create
our compute suite, today App
Engine and Cloud Functions.
Many of you probably
already know these products.
App Engine is our platform
for building web applications.
And Cloud Functions is
our event-driven functions
as a service offering.
For those perhaps unfamiliar
with App Engine, a quick recap.
Source-based
developer experience.
So you write your application
in your language of choice
and you deploy source
code to the environment.
It's great for running
your traditional web
app with your web framework
of choice, Express JS, Python
Flasks, Java Spring, et cetera.
And it also comes with
a range of features
that are necessary for
modern web applications
like versioning,
traffic splitting,
out of the box TLS encryption,
custom domains, et cetera.
Many of the run times that
we support this week are now
generally available--
GA, so PHP 7.2, Go
1.11, and Node 10.
Those run times are all GA.
We have some new versions
of run times coming up.
Java 11 is currently in alpha,
and the long awaited Ruby 2.5
now available on App Engine.
There are some other
sessions going on this week.
If you want to know
more about Ruby,
particularly there's
a session tomorrow,
and a general App
Engine session also
tomorrow if you're interested.
Cloud Functions
is, as I mentioned,
our event-driven functions
as a service offering.
Again, for those unfamiliar,
when you deploy a function,
it reacts to an event and
you can call other APIs.
And it's really the
sort of the glue code
solution in Cloud Platform.
Along the same vein, we have
new run times, GA, Python 3.7,
Node 8, Go 1.11,
and newly announced
this week on Cloud
Functions is Node 10 in beta
and Go 1.12 in alpha,
and finally, Java
is coming to Cloud Functions,
Java 8 in alpha this week.
And there's another
session you can go and look
at to learn more
about Java on Cloud
Platform, a serverless Java
developers journey tomorrow.
So they will tell you more
about how we do Java in GCP
on serverless.
Some new features
that we talked about
or we alluded to last
year on Cloud Functions.
And we'll go into a little
bit more detail now.
So max instances
last year we referred
to this as scaling controls.
What this allows
you to do is set
a maximum number of instances
of your Cloud Function.
So it sets an upper bound
of number of instances.
You configure this
at deployment time.
And it's really
useful for situations
where you have perhaps
a back end system that
has limited capacity.
So I'll just take you
through how that works.
The little cloud
is the internet.
So a request comes
into our front end,
and we'll route that request
to an instance of your Cloud
Function.
So far, so good.
As more requests come
in, more instances
of your Cloud Function
will be created,
assuming that the
current ones are
busy to serve those requests.
What max instances
allows you to do
is specify an upper
bound to that.
So you'll tell us in this
case, max instances of four.
We won't create more
than four instances.
Subsequent requests that
come in will be queued.
Now this is
important because you
may have a spike in traffic that
hits the boundary of your max
instances, but it
may only be temporary
and you don't want it
necessarily immediately reject
that request.
So the queuing gives
sort of a smoothing
effect to this spikiness
in the traffic.
Eventually, of course, if
the system is too overloaded,
meaning that the
requests in the front end
are too many for this max
instances to deal with,
then at some point,
that will be rejected.
But no matter what, if you have
your downstream system that
has a maximum
capacity, for example,
a database with the maximum
number of connections, then
the max instances will ensure
that you're not overloading
your underlying data set.
Overloading the
underlying database
will cause problems with all
serving functions potentially.
So that's max instances.
That's available now.
Another feature that
has also long awaited
is serverless VPC access.
So this allows you to connect
both Cloud Functions and App
Engine to your VPC.
Let's talk about
what that looks like.
So VPC today-- it's
available in Cloud Platform--
allows you to create a network
boundary around more than two
potentially, but in
this case, two regions.
So you have a shared
network address space.
With the serverless VPC
access via a connector,
you're able to send traffic
from your Cloud Function
into the VPC.
So if you have resources
in your VPC already,
maybe you have services
on a virtual machine
or you're hosting a
Redis cluster, whatever
it is, you can now access that
through Cloud Functions in App
Engine.
Additionally, if you
have on premises networks
connected to the cloud
via a VPN that are then
connected into the VPC, you
can route traffic all the way
from your Cloud
Function through the VPC
back to your on
premises infrastructure.
So as I mentioned,
great for accessing
services running on GCE or GKE.
If you're running a third
party solution hosted on a VM,
some Google services
are run in this network,
for example, Cloud Memorystore,
and any services running
in your own data center.
Rolling through the
features, I told
you had a lot to get through.
Per function identity--
what this allows you to do--
I'll skip this slide and go
to the more interesting one
with the nice
picture of the cat.
So let's say you had a function
that was reading from a Cloud
Storage bucket.
And you have a developer
that is wanting
to deploy this function that
reads from a Cloud Storage
bucket.
The function has an identity.
It has a service account in
the Google Cloud vernacular.
That identity has some
role associated with it.
And so in order
for that function
to read from the
storage bucket, the role
needs to have the
appropriate permissions,
needs to be able to have
the authority to read
from that storage bucket.
Now your developer may
have a different role.
He might be a developer, but
as a result of needing access
to the function that needs
access to the storage bucket,
by extension, this developer
implicitly needs the same role,
otherwise, there
is a possibility
of a privilege escalation.
So this is fine.
This is great.
This works.
Let's say you have
another function that
wants to read from
a different bucket.
Well previously,
both those functions
would have the same identity.
And if they had
the same identity,
that identity had
the same permissions,
which means that this
other bucket needs--
this other storage bucket
needs the same permissions
as the first one.
Well, there's a sort of
an implied level of access
here that you may not want.
You may not have intended
for your developer
to access this other bucket,
but you didn't really
have a way to opt out of that,
because both functions shared
the same identity.
But what we really
want to do is swap
that identity with a
different identity that
has a different role and a
different set of permissions,
gives the bucket the
appropriate level of access.
And this means that this
developer can no longer
access this bucket.
So it really gives
a narrowing effect
and a more fine grained control
over access control on a per
function basis.
Cloud Functions today can be
deployed in these four regions,
two in the US, one in
Europe, one in Asia.
This week we are
making available two
additional regions, one in
London and one in Hong Kong.
I'm going to switch
gears a little bit.
I mentioned we're talking about
serverless compute mostly.
This is part of the
mostly category.
Cloud Tasks-- for anyone who's
used App Engine in the past,
there is a feature of App
Engine called task queues which
is very, very popular feature,
asynchronous queuing product,
unfortunately, only available
if you're using App Engine.
Well, Cloud Tasks is the
first class GCP product
that does a very similar thing.
It's GA this week.
So let me just take you
through the canonical use
case for Cloud Tasks in
the context of serverless,
something like Cloud Functions.
So I mentioned you had
written a function that
does three things, whatever
those things may be.
The second part
of that let's say,
was a heavyweight
operation, maybe
it was transforming
an image or doing
some sort of heavyweight task
that you realize that doesn't
need to be synchronous.
It doesn't need to be
in the request flow.
It can happen at a later time.
Now, perhaps
traditionally you might
have spawned a thread to
process this asynchronous job
and returned quickly to the
client, to the requester.
Threads have this side
effect that they're perhaps
not durable.
If your process
fails completely,
what happens to that
asynchronous work?
The alternative is that
you can use Cloud Tasks.
So you in-queue a task.
It will happen in the
background asynchronously.
And then you return
quickly to the caller.
Some of the features,
additional features
which I'm going to
talk about in a second,
it has a configured
retry policy.
Again, with the sort of the
traditional way of perhaps
spawning a thread, if that
process that you spawn
the thread to execute
failed for some reason,
there's not necessarily a
durability and a retry policy
that you can apply to that.
So Cloud Tasks already
allows you to do that.
There's rate limiting
dynamic scheduling.
This is really cool.
You can say execute this thing,
but do it in one hour from now.
You can target the output.
In this case on screen, I'm
not really concerned about what
happens after.
But you can target
arbitrary HTTP endpoints.
And you can add authentication.
I'll talk about that
in a little bit.
That's also new this week.
It's a little bit more about
rate limiting and retry
in Cloud Tasks.
So similar to the situation
I described before
with max instances where you
have a back end system that
has some sort of
capacity limit, you
can use max instances to
control the flow of traffic
into that back end.
But sometimes it's
hard to determine
how many instances you need.
If your back end system is an
API that has literally a rate
limit, you can only call this
API n times every n minutes.
How many instances
do I need to make
sure I don't exceed that rate?
Well, it depends, right?
It depends on how quickly
you're able to call the API.
With rate limiting
in Cloud Tasks,
let's say you had a
situation where you exceeded
the limit off the back end.
So what you could
do is put a queue
in front of it using Cloud
Tasks with a rate limit.
So let's walk through this.
You have a bunch of requests
coming in to Cloud Functions.
Those Cloud Functions are
in-queuing tasks on to a queue.
The queue itself
has a rate limit.
So no matter what,
the HVAC system
is not going to be overloaded.
And so you just have
that rate limit match
whatever the capacity
of your back end is.
If, for whatever
reason, some requests
fails on that back end, you
can configure at retry policy
so that there's an element
of durability and reliability
to it.
And there's another
session on Thursday
that talks more
about asynchronous
tasks using Cloud Tasks.
Cloud Scheduler-- is
everyone keeping up?
I'm not going to say
very much about this.
It's great because it's simple.
It's a managed cron service.
So you can schedule
repeating executions.
You can also have a retry
policy if your execution failed.
You can have arbitrary HTTP.
So you could use Cloud
Schedule and Cloud
Tasks to trigger something
off Cloud Platform, just
anything that's available
on an HTTP endpoint.
And it also includes
this authentication,
which I'm going to
talk about in a moment.
And there's another session
there again on Thursday
that uses Cloud
Scheduler extensively.
So I mentioned in a
couple of scenarios
this idea of Cloud
Scheduler and Cloud Tasks
emitting or calling
services via HTTP.
And this has perhaps
a problem where
the service that's receiving
this call from Cloud
Task or Cloud Scheduler needs
to validate and authenticate
the person calling them.
If you set up stand
up a web server
to be called on a
schedule, how do you
know that it's Google Cloud
scheduler calling you?
How do you verify that identity?
And more importantly,
if it was just well,
I can verify that it's
Google Cloud, that's great.
But how do I know
it's my Google Cloud?
How do I know it's my project
and not some other Google Cloud
project calling me?
So let's say you're
executing your Cloud Function
or you're executing some
arbitrary HTTP end point that's
out there on the internet.
Well, you can associate-- in
the same way you associate
an identity to a Cloud Function
that we described earlier,
you can associate an
identity to the resource
that is sending you
these pings, that
sending you these requests.
So your Cloud Scheduler job
or your Cloud Tasks queue
will have an identity.
At the time the HTTP
request is sent,
we will put an open ID connect
JWT token in the HTTP header
that corresponds
to that identity.
It's a token that expires, but
when you receive that token,
you can validate that using
standard open protocols
to validate the authenticity of
the claims made in that token.
I mentioned Cloud Tasks
and Cloud Scheduler.
This capability is also
available as of today
in Pub/Sub.
So Cloud Pub/Sub also
allows you to push.
And it has a push
subscription allows
you to push messages to HTTP.
Now you can attach an
identity to your subscription
in Cloud Pub/Sub.
When it pushes the HTTP
requests the message,
it will carry with
it a bare token
an open ID connect JWT token.
So that's all the
things that we've
been working on in
the last 12 months
in terms of Cloud Functions,
App Engine, Cloud Tasks, Cloud
Schedule.
But this is Cloud Next,
so what are we doing next?
Many of you may have
already seen some of this,
but here we go.
So traditionally
serverless has a couple
of these characteristics.
It's typically source driven.
You write your code, function,
or app, whatever it might be.
Obviously, it's
serverless, so I don't
want any operational overhead.
So it's no ops.
And it has a characteristic
that you typically
pay only when you're using it.
It scales to zero.
But some things can
be constraining.
So adding custom libraries
or native binaries
can sometimes be cumbersome.
Arbitrary run times-- we talked
about the runtime support
expanding on App Engine
and Cloud Functions.
But what if I want to
run Erlang or Rust?
Well, you're sort of requiring
the platform providers
to do that, and to do a lot of
work before you can get that.
Well, there's another solution
that people have been using
for this and it's containers.
And so the container
is sort of the lingua
franca of portability of code.
So it's obviously
container driven.
Unfortunately, most
container platforms
do have at least
some amount of ops.
You're creating a cluster.
You're managing a
cluster of containers.
And the billing
model is typically
you pay for the instances
of the machines that
are running your containers.
But it has these
advantages where
you can specify
arbitrary libraries,
arbitrary run times.
It operates in a very similar
way to a virtual machine.
So what we're
announcing this week
is a new product in GCP
called Cloud Run which brings
those two worlds together.
So you get all the
benefits of a container
being able to run an arbitrary
runtime, arbitrary custom
libraries.
You specify whatever you
want in that container.
But we give you all
the operational model
of a serverless product.
So you have no ops.
You only pay when
it's being used.
So we're going to talk
a little bit about this.
There's three aspects that
we identify with Cloud Run.
One is container to
production in seconds.
This was a really hard
requirement for us.
It's one thing to say, well,
you can run a container.
But if you have to jump
through 20 hoops to get there,
then it's not really serverless.
There's no rule book that says
serverless has to be easy,
but we all know that that's
how we want it to be.
So I should be able to give
Google a Docker image and curly
URL in a few seconds.
It's natively serverless.
What does that mean?
Well, if you go onto the Cloud
Console and you create a Cloud
Run serverless, it will
be serverless by default.
It will be no ops.
You pay only for what you use.
It scales up fast.
It scales to zero, et cetera.
And the last point is it's
one developer experience
wherever you want to go.
I'll talk more about
this a little bit later.
But we also have a
version of Cloud Run
that runs on your GKE cluster.
So if you're already
a GKE customer
or you already have made
investment in Kubernetes
and that's where you want to
run the bulk of your workload,
you may have
developers internally
that want some of the
agility and benefits
of the serverless
developer experience
where I just have to deploy
and I get something back
in seconds.
Well, you can run that same
capability on your GKE cluster.
And some of you may have
encountered this term Knative.
I'll talk a little bit
more about that as well.
So Cloud Run is Google
Cloud's implementation
of the Knative
serving specification.
I'll pause that
and leave it there.
I'll come back to it later.
It's very simple.
It looks like this.
If you literally take a
photo of that OCR and type
into Google Console, it
will work, but rather
than do that, let me show you.
This is a Cloud Console.
I'm logged into the
Cloud Run section.
So here on the left nav, we have
a new option called Cloud Run.
Over here, I just
have a Cloud Shell.
I'm not going to
do anything fancy.
I just wanted to
show you how easy it
is to create and deploy a
new service as a container
using Cloud Run.
So I have a very simple
Node JS application.
In fact, I'm so
lazy, I literally
copied it from the Hello
World example on Express JS.
The only thing I changed
is this port variable.
But other than that,
it's identical.
I have a package.Jason.
For those familiar with Node
will know what that means.
For those not, it's the
canonical deployment descriptor
for Node JS.
The only thing I changed here
is this start command here.
And so if I just run--
I have to specify my port--
if I just run that regular old
NPM, nothing fancy going on,
and I preview that
in the browser,
we'll get Hello Cloud Next.
Let's just quickly change
that to prove that it's real.
I don't know if I
have to restart,
but let's do it anyway.
Refresh.
OK, so that's real.
So I have a index
JS at package.Jason.
The only other file I have
here is a Docker file.
And this is pretty lightweight.
It's just inheriting from
the default official Node
JS 10 image.
It runs in NPM install.
And then it calls NPM starts
the same command I just
called in the console.
Well, I have a Docker file, but
Cloud Run takes Docker images.
So how do I turn my Docker
file into a Docker image?
I could run Docker
Build locally.
And that would produce an image.
And upload it to repository.
And that would work.
But we have a service actually,
that will do this for me.
Here's my cheat sheet.
So I'm going to use a product
that we have in Cloud called
Cloud Build that--
surprise, surprise--
builds Docker images.
So live demo, let's
see if it works.
Of course it's going to work.
I have Cloud Build over here.
Let's refresh that.
There it is.
You can see I did a few earlier.
Takes about 20 or 30 seconds.
It's still building.
And it's done.
There it is.
So that has given me
this image down here.
So this is a Docker
image in the repository
that has my Node Jason.
So all I need to do now
is go into Cloud Run.
Going to create a service.
First thing it's going to ask
is for my container image URL
that I just created.
It's picked up the name by
default. My location is fine.
I'm going to check this box.
What this is saying
is let me hit the URL
without any authentication.
Now by default, it's off.
You need to
authenticate yourself
against your own service, just
with your Google Cloud account.
For the purpose
of this demo, I'm
going to make it public so
I can hit it without having
to do any of that.
And I'm just going to create.
So what this is going to do is--
so I already built
my Docker image.
It's uploaded to the repository.
This is going to pull down that
image, set up all the routing
and configuration necessary,
and make my service available.
And you see it gave me a URL.
It generated a TLS
certificate for me.
If I click that URL,
it does my service.
[APPLAUSE]
There's something else
I'll just give you
a little sneak peek at that
I'll come back to later.
Avert your eyes.
It's yaml.
I wanted to just point
out that the first line--
this is the yaml file
description of the service
that I just created.
It's a Knative
compatible service.
Now for those that aren't
familiar with what kind Knative
means, that it's not going I
mean a lot to you right now.
I do have some
slides later on that
will start to make more sense.
Back to slides.
Can we switch back
to the slides?
Pretty please?
That was Hello World.
So what do you get?
Well, when you deploy a Cloud
Run service you get HTTPS.
We didn't demonstrate
this, but you can also
add a custom domain so
within a few minutes
you can start your
container-based web
application, add
your custom domain,
and you're off to the races.
The allow authentication
on or off tick box
that I mentioned
before, well, we
talked about the
identity-based authentication
for Cloud Tasks, Cloud
Scheduler, and Pub/Sub.
Well, we will automatically
validate that token for you.
So if you leave that tick
box unticked, and then you
in-queue a task
into task queues,
let's say, that's pushing via
HTTP to your Cloud Run service,
we'll handle all that
authentication for you.
So the Cloud Runs
service is not invokable
from the outside world,
but it is invocable by you
either directly, if you
authenticate yourself,
or asynchronously via
one of these services.
So HTTPS plus the
open ID connect JWT.
And it's automatically
validated, as I mentioned.
OK, I want to
sidebar just quickly
to talk about concurrency.
When we use the term
instance, that's
what we use to describe an
instantiation of your function
app or container, in this case.
It's typically where
you nominate resources
like memory and CPU.
Importantly, it has
a lifecycle that
might be beyond your request.
So it will create an instance.
You send a request to
it, we serve the request.
That doesn't mean
we instantly kill
the instance, because of
course, another request might
be coming.
And we want to save
that cold start time.
So an instance has
its own lifecycle.
And then concurrency,
the way we refer to it
is the number of requests
processed at the same time
on a single instance.
So it looks like this.
A request comes in, same diagram
as before, hits the front end,
and is served by instances.
Now in the case of a product
like Cloud Functions,
concurrency is one and
you can't change it.
One function will deal with
one request at one time.
And that's great because
it means the programming
model is very simple.
The billing model
is very simple.
While your request is running,
you're paying the end.
But there's a problem.
Well, your function may not
be using all the resources
on that instance all the time.
And CPU is the
biggest culprit here.
You're not you're
unlikely to be CPU-bound
for the entire duration
of your function.
You're going to be I/O bound.
You're going to be doing
other things, network
bound in some way.
So zooming in on
in this scenario,
it might be better if we could
utilize more of the machine
during the request,
if we could move
some of that CPU
utilization into the gaps
of another instance.
And we would do this by
changing concurrency.
But why is this new?
We've been doing this forever
on virtual machines well
it's not new, but it's
new for serverless.
And particularly, it's
new for serverless
because the serverless billing
model has traditionally been
you pay for a
lifetime of a request.
Well, what is the
lifetime of request
if there are more than one?
How do we make
concurrency serverless?
Well, here's a way
of describing it.
Here's my instance.
The instance has a
lifecycle, as I mentioned,
that may be beyond the
lifecycle of your request.
A request starts and ends
over a period of time.
And in the traditional model,
that's what you would pay for.
You'd pay while that
request is being served.
Well, what happens
when another request
comes in offset to that?
First one starts, second
one starts, first one ends,
second one ends.
Well, pretty simple.
We just extend it
to the boundary.
So the billable time
now becomes the time
where at least one concurrent
request is being served.
So why do we want
to do concurrency?
Why do we want to
complicate our lives?
Well, there's a couple of
really important benefits.
One is you have
fewer cold starts.
Imagine a ramp up in QPS.
If every instance of your
function or application
can only deal with one
request at the same time,
every subsequent
request that comes in
at approximately the same time
needs to spawn a new instance.
And spawning a new instance
creates a cold start.
Well, if you can serve
some of those requests
on an existing instance,
you have necessarily
fewer cold starts,
you therefore,
have a faster ramp up if
you have a spike in traffic.
And importantly, you
have better utilization.
So the underlying
machinery is going
to be better utilized, which
has both speed, efficiency,
and cost implications.
The one caveat is
that you give away
some of the simplicity
in the programming model.
If you're storing
state in global scope
outside of your function,
for example, or outside
of your app, well,
you have to be aware
that there may be more than one
request concurrently accessing
that global state.
So maybe don't do that.
And you do open yourself
up to more rate conditions
if things are competing.
So I want to invite my colleague
Michael onto the stage.
He's going to do
a much better demo
than mine that will show
you some of these benefits.
MICHAEL ABD-EL-MALEK:
Thanks Jason.
Jason, do you switch?
JASON POLITES: Yeah.
MICHAEL ABD-EL-MALEK: So
I'm excited to be talking
about some of the work
we've been doing in CloudOne
to achieve fast scaling.
So why is fast
scaling important?
Well, for serverless
workloads, we
tend to have bursty
requests stream.
And so for these
bursts, we want to be
able to quickly react and
handle all the requests
with low latency.
And of course, we don't want
to be paying for instances
when we're not using them.
And so we want to scale down.
And as Jason mentioned, if
we have too many instances,
then we have a lot
of cold starts,
and then we have the higher
latency associated with that.
So the trade-off for the balance
we're trying to strike here
is to create lots of
instances on demand as needed,
but not to create too many
so that both the cold start
latencies and the bill is
appropriate for that workload.
And so what I'm going
to be demoing here
is kind of the fast
scaling that we
have for CloudOne that's
an order of magnitude
faster than what we've had
in our existing serverless
products like App
Engine and GCF.
And so here's a monitor
of how many instances
we have right now.
I'm going to deploy an existing
image that I've already built.
And then the workload is
going to be pretty simple.
I'm going to use
Apache Bench to send
10,000 concurrent requests.
Each one of these requests
are just burning CPU
and executing for one second.
So given that I set maximum
currency equal to one
in this deployment, and I have
10,000 requests, I expect--
concurrent clients, rather--
around 10,000 clients
on the order.
And I'll explain why
later it's a bit higher.
So let me start
the workload now.
There's some lag
in this monitoring.
And then you see the number
of instances start up.
And it's just it's
a matter of seconds
we're going to see around
10,000 instances startup.
And so this is pretty cool.
And you can see that
the number of instances
slightly overshoots
above 10,000.
And the reason we
do that is we need
to be able to handle any
spike of workloads that's
higher than like, if we're
going to get to more requests,
we want to be able
to handle that.
And we also want to not
have the instances have
too high of utilization.
Whoops.
OK.
So the test is now done.
So request test is done.
And so that's OK.
I loaded quickly.
I started 10,000 instances,
you can see here,
in a matter of seconds.
In less than 10 seconds, I
started 8,000 instances here.
And so for my next demo
what I want to show
is what Jason
referred to earlier
in terms of concurrency.
Most requests aren't spending
all the time burning CPU.
They may be doing
requests to kind of say
Cloud Machine Learning
or Google Cloud Storage.
And so we can have concurrent
requests at the same time.
And so when I deploy,
I can get say,
how many concurrent
requests I wanted.
In this case, I'm going to
say I want five requests.
And now I'm deploying
a new version,
and instances are not shared
between revisions, even
if the same service.
And so I'm going to have cold
start for the new workload
that I want now.
And so here we go.
There's zero
instances right now.
It's pretty old school.
I'm going to run Apache Bench
on five different machines,
starting 10,000 concurrent
requests on each one of them.
And then, as was
a previous test,
you expect to see
kind of a rapid scale
up to an order of
10,000 instances.
But unlike the
previous tests, we're
now having multiple
requests per instance.
And so we're getting an order
of 50,000 requests per second.
This test runs for around
a minute and a half.
So these are pretty
impressive numbers.
But why do we need this
kind of rapid scaling?
I want to give you a few
examples of customers use cases
that we've had on App Engine and
GCF and Google Cloud Functions.
And so on App Engine,
"New York Times"
hosts a crossword puzzle.
So every day when the
crossword puzzle is released,
there's a significant ramp up
in terms of customer of clients
trying to get the crossword.
And because in App Engine,
we didn't scale this fast,
the "New York Times" tends to
ramp up manually, instances
to handle that load.
Well, with this rapid
scaling, customers
don't have to think about that.
They don't have to predict
how much load is coming in.
The system will very
quickly scale up
to a necessary
number of instances.
Another example is Snap runs
most of the compute workload
on App Engine.
And they do very
rapid deployments.
They want to do deployments
of new code every few minutes.
And when you have millions
of queries per second
to a large service like Snap,
you want to be able to handle--
kind of migrate
from the old version
to the newer version
really quickly.
And so this kind
of rapid scaling
allows us to spin up a
lot of the new containers
for the new version and
migrate traffic quickly
to the new version.
Now, you'll see here as the
client requests went down,
we're down to 280 instances,
but you're not paying for that.
So we quickly spun them
down, but you're only
paying for the instances that
are running your workload.
And so these instances
are available,
because we let the
garbage collect them
in case we want to--
you get more requests.
And so I just want to
add that we have a shared
infrastructure for App
Engine, Google Cloud
Function, and CloudOne.
And we're going to be enabling
this in Google Cloud Functions
as well.
App Engine's
building model makes
it difficult to support
this because there's
a minimum of 15 minute
billing for the instance.
So we're only going to
enable this and CloudOne
and Google Cloud Functions.
And then finally, just
a couple of caveats.
We, by default, we are
limiting every CloudOne service
to 1,000 instances.
But if you need
more, let us know,
and we'll increase our
limit, something like 10,000
if you need.
And we just doubled our
data center capacity.
And the other caveat is we're
kind of this fast scaling
is brand new.
We're still finely tuning it.
And so it's not enabled
for all projects yet,
but we're going to be enabling
it shortly for every project.
So I gave a few examples
of customer use cases
for this kind of rapid scaling.
And we want to put this out
there and see how you use it.
And we're excited to see
how you use this capability.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
JASON POLITES: I
just want to reflect
a moment on what we just saw.
Michael sent some
load to a service
that went from 0
to 10,000 instances
in a matter of seconds.
It really is incredible.
And my colleagues
back at the office
told me to say it's over 9,000.
I didn't really know
what that meant.
So just in summary,
serverless compute
on Google Cloud, Cloud
Functions, App Engine, and now
the new service Cloud Run.
There's a great session--
if you want to know more about
Cloud Run, which is today
actually, this
afternoon, Container Once
Serverless Everywhere--
Anywhere, rather.
Circling back to the
start, I mentioned
this thing called Knative.
For those unfamiliar, Knative
is an open source community
developed platform
that allows you
to build, deploy, and manage
modern serverless workloads.
It all starts with
Kubernetes and Istio.
We've defined these three
categories of components.
There's Knative Build, Knative
Serving, Knative Eventing.
Cloud Run that you've seen
is the middle component.
It's the serving part of
the Knative specification.
And above all of that, there's
a declarative API service.
We use that term declarative.
It's a Kubernetes
style API service.
I showed you the yaml file
before of the Cloud Run
service.
That is the declaration
of that service
that you would send to Knative
to instantiate or to provision
the resources necessary
for that resource
in your Knative
cluster or service,
If it's in the
case of Cloud Run.
It's been community developed.
We've been working closely with
folks like Pivotal, IBM, SAP,
Redhat, et cetera, to design
a serverless developer
experience and a
serverless platform that
meets the needs of customers.
As I mentioned, it's based
on Kubernetes and Istio.
Cloud Run is our
instantiation of Knative.
Cloud Run is the fullest
serverless, fully managed,
pay for what you use.
You can also run
Cloud Run on GKE,
and they are both
compatible with Knative.
So I haven't gone very
deep on the Knative side.
I'd encourage you to
look more into it.
There's a session
that covers how to use
Knative in hybrid use cases.
That is on Thursday.
If you want to know
more about Knative,
I'd encourage you
to get on to that.
So that's the end.
We made it.
Don't forget to write.
And I think we
probably don't have
time for a lot of questions.
So Michael and I
will make ourselves
available outside the room
immediately after this session.
And if you to know more, these
are the canonical locations
for Cloud Run and for
serverless on GCP.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]